how's it going bros before this video
begins I wanted to share something a
little bit personal it's a project that
I've been working on with Arman the goat
simulator guy through the studio double
moose we're launching our first game
animal super squad it's short for ass I
think you guys are gonna really love it
it's a really funny game I'm gonna link
it in the description and you should add
it to your wish list to make sure that
you get it when it comes out next week
on Tuesday let's show some bits of the
trailer
[Music]
getting seen today we're playing a new
game that I have invented it's called
[Music]
they're always simple you laugh you
loose I have never laughed once in my
entire life if you laugh no let's begin
the challenge I cook good I'm Edgar Lord
in night good this is not Christian this
is not a Christian thing get it away
from me I'll keep watching just to
understand what this is
well someone just give her a hamburger
[Music]
okay okay that's quite that's quite
enough although I do agree with the
message it's not very Christian so I'm
gonna have to stop it there are these
streaming is that what's happening here
there's a stream troll messages now
that's just offensive
[Music]
I feel bad I feel bad but I didn't laugh
not even for a second
hey were you calling me a liar now get
out of here
[Music]
as I can I think this is Facebook group
that collects just really bad English
from people trying to hit on women a few
as I can as you can hey you got that
thumbs put my ass in your [ __ ]
Oh oh my god what a legend this guy a
baby's falling up with balloons hey you
wanna smoke what a legendary video my
god who is this man
I've seen this one this one is insane
dear life and just thinking about it oh
my god no I understand that people had
different ways of dealing with stress
but surely playing it off as something
that it's not Anna what do I know
it just looks doesn't it doesn't look
nice
okay just listen to her she says it like
it's a funniest thing in the world okay
so another one of these Eastern European
that looks disgusting
as a Polish you know just you who would
want to dancing they not me
what's the point of this to make me feel
disgusted oh oh oh
[Music]
what a fine editing work there with the
music well done that was hilarious what
in the world I think it's real like the
guy is just probably just really cold
maybe on drugs as well but my god he
looks insane imagine is filming a random
party in comes Gollum out of nowhere no
not funny
this short one is this is stupid it's
like you don't expect to see that I
don't know why am i sit I still want to
see this wouldn't I guess I don't know
why that was so funny to me it just
looks so free what is wrong with him
goddamn boy wait this guy is swedish i
think is an author or something like
that
swedish
it's a weird that I understand some of
these like uh yeah it's like yeah when I
say I think you know what I said there I
got trolled I got to see guys make up
instead of girls oh [ __ ] guys making out
it's disgusting cuz I am NOT a
homosexual cuz it's not Christian that's
why no other reason monetize my
Christian videos thank you
15 minutes I used the computer before
into the store when I came back my
history was gone the cache was cleared
and the cookies had been reset
know what that's that's crazy I think
sometimes the computer runs an automatic
software update so maybe that just of
course the automatic update and you
click OK and then it gets installed so
computer one of those things whenever
gets interrupted from the power source
it has to reboot and it just totally
wipes out the history beyond this babe
it's porn right anyways I mean every guy
does perfectly okay with that as long as
it's not that weird stuff
[Music]
none of that matters the only thing that
matters that when we're doing it I'm
thinking about you and you're thinking
about me right oh what a brilliant
sketch that was hilarious I don't watch
any horse stuff just for the record what
a turn I like that one a lot
well that was it for another you laugh
you lose did you laugh or did you lose
it'll be honest leave a comment down
below and let me know I really like this
one there's probably one of the better
ones how about that how about that
hopefully this video didn't get
copyrighted claimed age-restricted
demonetised and i can keep making them
leave a like if you enjoyed watching
really appreciate it and feel free to
leave suggestions on your life your a
lot in the reddit so that more of you
can do my work for me eventually you
will all just merge into one entity that
will somehow take over until then this
is a pretty sound plan appreciate you
guys love you guys so much as always
you're the heart is stronger than the